Je ne pense vraiment pas qu'il y ait une raison
pour laquelle quelqu'un comme moi ne devrait pas être
considéré comme normal quand j'étais
plus jeune J'ai subi environ 30 interventions chirurgicales J'étais
toujours à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur des
hôpitaux  les oreilles et le nez quand j'étais
plus jeune, j'étais vraiment mécontent parce que
j'étais toujours dans et hors des cris ou des
rendez-vous.
ma famille
qui ne m'a pas tout à fait évalué et je pense
que si c'était définitivement un tournant
pour moi alors que je vieillissais vers l'âge de
12 13 peut-être 11 ans, je suis devenu plus
conscient du monde.
Personnellement, j'aime littéralement la mode et
puis je  ont commencé à photographier avec
des photographes de mode qui voulaient
photographier avec des modèles non ou atypiques des
personnes très différentes de votre
standard tout le monde n'est pas né cette
créature parfaite tout le monde a ses propres
attributs physiques ainsi que sa
vie  tyles et je ne pense vraiment pas qu'il
y ait une raison pour laquelle quelqu'un comme moi
ne devrait pas être considéré comme normal
lorsqu'on lui donne les mêmes opportunités que
n'importe qui d'autre
[Musique]
notre Moïse Elijah affecte également les glandes
de mon corps afin que je ne puisse pas transpirer  correctement et
je peux me déshydrater très facilement cela
affecte également les glandes de mes yeux et les
glandes de mes lèvres Je suppose que je suis aussi
techniquement légalement aveugle Je ne vois pas
très bien et je souscris à la dysplasie
car cela affecte également les petits os de
mon corps  J'étais à moitié sourd quand
j'étais plus jeune, mon message principal au monde
est de vraiment s'accepter et de
ne laisser personne d'autre vous dire
qui vous êtes ou comment vivre votre vie
, le voyage de ma vie n'a définitivement été
rien  comme la façon dont les autres
essaient de le faire pour moi, je ne me laisse
pas voir pourquoi je devrais être autre chose que
m'accepter et m'aimer
comme tout le monde devrait être
toi